first on cbs this morning house speaker
nancy pelosi joins us to discuss the
legacy that lewis has left behind
he served more than 30 years in congress
and just four months ago
lewis marched with nancy pelosi and
other lawmakers to mark the 55th
anniversary
of bloody sunday in selma alabama i love
this
picture house speaker nancy pelosi joins
us to discuss
good morning to you madam speaker oh
what a life he lived i've been thinking
about it as we all have
all weekend and i'm wondering what when
was the last conversation you had with
him
if you're comfortable sharing what you
two talked about
the last conversation i had with him was
on thursday
and that was a sad one i didn't know it
was the last
but i had had some conversations with
him but we never talked about
his dying until until that day and
talks about he always said he wanted to
go home
so he was going home to heaven
you know i stayed up last night watching
the documentary good trouble it's really
good highly recommended on amazon you're
featured
in the documentary and in it you said
that he really was
the conscience he challenged the
conscience of the congress
how so well i i
i love that documentary because of it
says so much
i did tell you about john but there's so
much more
because he was just remarkable every
single day i served with him for 33
years
in the congress of the united states and
he
again challenged our conscience in so
many ways
in terms of equality and justice
and it was justice for all of course he
made his mark
for equality in the south and voting
rights
but for the african-american community
but he went well beyond that
he stood with us when we introduced the
equality act
which was to end discrimination against
the lgbtq
community he stood with us and we were
talking about
women's rights and everything that that
involves
he stood with us when we passed the
affordable care act
and it saddens me to say that when he
was helping us
with that that was 2010
there were people who were picketing the
capital and
and they now this is only 2010 this that
recently
that recent they shouted profanities
that him
they
they spat on him 10 years ago
so there's something that you know our
work has
not been done but what the most
wonderful thing that i love
about the very end of his life the last
really public
appearance that he made was to go and
identify with black lives matter
painted on the street with the mayor of
washington d.c
his connection to all of that it's such
an iconic
moment such an iconic photo
right before that he had had shortly
before that he had had a town hall
meeting
with president obama another
connection to the future someone the
president
obama being inspired by john lewis so
he yeah madam speaker
he he was very proud he told us of the
black lives matter and was very
insistent that there would be peaceful
protest
always i noticed you got choked up when
you were talking about him being spat
upon
i i totally understand the pain of that
he he seemed to love a country
that sometimes didn't love him back he
was able to do that
well he was a patriot he was a patriot
and the one thing about john is
he was truly committed to non-violence
in every way as was reverend vivian who
died the very same day he did such a
coincidence but the the uh the thing
and when his non-violence took him to a
place that led him to respect people
even who disagreed with him so
vehemently that they would engage in an
act of violence
but he would um he would reach out
in friendship always he was very he was
saying
in that regard not only but many of us
could
do that yeah yeah saintly
this is the other thing he was able
i'm sorry this is in my colleague jim
kyburn who's with
the half democratic whip of the house he
he said it's a good thing i wasn't with
john on some of his uh challenges
because i'm not sure i would have been
as non-violent as he was in the face of
some of the
the attacks that were made on him
i heard him say that he said he didn't
think that he would have the restraint
that john lewis had you know the other
thing about him
is that people on both sides of the
aisle wanted to be associated with him
he was able to bridge that gap
especially during these times
how was he able to do that do you think
well he was really a very special person
and the respect that he had for every
person
came back to him you're so right on both
sides of the island both sides of the
capitol
and by and large down pennsylvania
avenue
most of the time he had a great command
of great respect
and had great rapport he did believe
he did believe that all of us had a
spark of divinity
in us that made us worthy of respect
and he treated people with in that
in that vein and that they had the spark
of divinity and he did too
and that called upon him uh to
rise to a higher level of engagement so
he was a model
to the rest of us i sent a note to my
colleagues this morning and said
in terms of arrangements and the rest
but i closed it i said
we all of us who worked with john in
congress knew that he
always worked on the side of the angels
and now he is with them so
so as we remember him and we celebrate
him today
two things i'm curious what you're
thinking how can congress best honor him
and how can we the people best honor him
well i'll tell you what my granddaughter
said she's ten she loved john
and all my great children and
grandchildren do but children loved him
no wonder he did a comic book because he
connected with them
in every possible way but in any event
she said
well she cried when she heard he passed
and then she said well why didn't they
revive him
why didn't they revive him they said
well he he's passed he's going home to
heaven
and she said well then we'll just have
to make sure his ideas live
and that's probably how we all congress
and otherwise
honor john lewis one way we could is for
the senate to pass
the voting rights act and name it for
john lewis that would be a very
appropriate way
to honor him most immediately
all right madam speaker you know people
let's see let's see how this turns out
let's see how this turns out that would
be quite a tribute to him
thank you very much for taking the time
with us this morning thank you thank you
appreciate it thank